Arielle winter Adam Levine demi lovato
and more stars celebrate Halloween I'm
excited
All Hallows Eve hasn't arrived yet but
some of our favorite celebs are getting
in on the scary fun I wanted to have
something that made a statement that she
definitely did demi lovato looked like a
spitting image of singer selena
quintanilla in this purple ensemble long
dark hair and black high heels while
Sarah Hyland coordinated her stranger
things costume the former bachelorette
contestant Wells Adams sparking romance
rumors between the pair it's fresh Kim
and Kourtney Kardashian nailed their
Halloween costumes channeling the king
and queen of pop Madonna and Michael
Jackson circa the 1991 Academy Awards
really cute Arielle Wintour flaunted her
curves alongside boyfriend Levi's Medan
in matching skeleton costumes and Adam
Levine revealed on Instagram he quote
rated wife Behati Prinsloo closet while
putting together his Rockstar inspired
ensemble captioning the pic of his look
wearing girl stuff is not easy respect
to the females
[Music]
you